scott we always hear about a person
writing this dream script it's their
first
project they've had it for years and it
just pours out of them in one weekend
how many times have you seen a writer's
first time script
actually be sold or optioned never never
i've never personally seen it um and i
think that that's a fantastic
dream scenario i believe that those
stories really stem from writers who
actually have a career in motion
and they have contacts they can reach
out to and it's not that they sit and
actually write a screenplay over 48
hours
it's that they have an idea and they
already have a team of people who trust
them
because they've delivered so many
quality scripts in the past
a newbie writer from scratch throwing an
idea to a major studio and expecting a
check in the mail or some
a big contract with an agent i've never
seen it happen
and i think that maybe a script has
moved from point a to point b
and has maybe moved up the channels by
the time that movie reached the screen
i don't think it had any similarities to
the original idea
and i'm not sure that the writer
received anything from it either i've
never heard of it
so most people that either sell or
option their work
what is this their third fourth fifth
time writing a script i mean
when from when you talk to people what
seems to be the general amount that
they've gone through the drafts the
actual incarnation of a story i think
you need at least
two to three ready to go
feature length scripts or two to three
ready to go
tv spec script ideas that are
completely ready to present to the
marketplace
and that takes time to get to but i
think you need that in your arsenal as a
minimum
to be taken seriously by decision makers
and to showcase your skills
you